JHYUN CHUNG: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for standing
in that long line.
Well, the weather's
beautiful today,
but I really appreciate it.
Hi.
My name is Jhyun Chung.
I'm a business development
manager in Google Play.
In my daily job, I work
with Korean developers
based in Seoul.
And internally, I lead a team
of other BDs to help you guys
do better in your Go Global
efforts, more focused on apps.
In this session, I will
talk about the opportunities
of the APAC market, especially
focusing on Japan, Korea,
Southeast Asia.
You saw it on the title,
but we'll be also talking
about Taiwan and Hong Kong.
And we will talk about
the users in that market,
also about experiences
from other developers'
success stories, and the
tips and Google tools
that you can go back home and
start implementing right away.
So I'm not the first
one telling you this,
but Google Play is
truly a global platform,
and you can reach
almost anywhere
in the world with Google Play.
I would like to start with
a code that I really love.
We hear developers say that
Google Play has fundamentally
changed the way how
they do business.
And in the case of
smart study, the CEO
gave this wonderful code.
They open doors
through Play, but went
beyond Play maybe to YouTube and
to retail presence and so on.
So Google Play just
was the trigger
to expand their
business globally.
It's like-- I don't know
if you know this animation.
There's a Japanese character
who has this magical door where
he opens it.
He can basically enter any
place that he wants to go.
I feel that Google Play
is that door for you.
You could open and go into any
market that you want to go.
And today, we're going
to open the markets APAC.
The Asian market is the
single largest market
that we have on Play.
According to App
Annie, the countries
that I will cover today--
Japan, Korea, Taiwan, Hong
Kong, and Southeast
Asia-- they make
the 50% of total revenue
in the mobile app business.
That's basically the
half of the market.
So does this portion
resonate with your business?
No.
Yes.
Yes and no.
If it doesn't, this may mean
this much more opportunity
of your business to grow.
Not only APAC is
all about revenue.
It's about huge growth
in install base.
Again, according
to App Annie, we
see that the instill
growth rate, especially
in Southeast Asia, is
54% higher than that
of the global average.
It's really a great
growth that we're
seeing in these APAC markets.
But the reality
is not that easy.
It's not rosy.
How many of you
know all the games
that you see on this screen?
It's a screen shot
that I took from Korea
in top grossing chart
ranking yesterday.
Do recognize the games?
Anyone?
Well, as you can see, there
aren't many global titles
that you easily recognize from.
Let's move on to Japan.
I took it on the same day.
Do you see any duplicates?
Can you recognize?
It's kind of difficult, right?
Actually there is one.
And not a lot of
global titles again.
What this means is
local developers
are really dominating
these markets.
So a really tough
competition there.
And does this sound
like a barrier?
Does this discourage you?
One of the human errors
that we easily make
is we make conclusions
too fast even
if we don't know the full
information to base off
that conclusion.
So today, let's talk about
what would be the key levers
to move the needles
in APAC market,
and let's have it and
take it on your business
and really explore together
what could work better for you.
So what makes it so different?
Before I go into
the details, let
me ask you a quick question.
How many of you are
game developers?
Raise your hand.
OK.
A little less than I expected.
How many of you are non-game
developers, app developers?
Great.
OK.
And some of you are
just in between.
That's good if you're starting
and you're recruiting,
that's still fine.
There is a old Asian
Confucius saying
that if three people walk
together, at least one of them
is my teacher.
Meaning, if it doesn't directly
applies to your business,
take a learning from
there, understand
what is behind that logic, and
take it into your business.
App developers can
learn from games.
Games can also learn from apps.
So let's do that.
Let's have that
mindset together.
So on the very
basic-- when we talk
about going global, very easy
pitfalls that developers fall
into would be they
think it's OK enough
to build an app that works
well in their country, which
could be making sense.
Because if you're just going to
the local market, that's fine.
But if you're going
to the global market,
this is totally a
different story.
You have to be aware that
infrastructure is very much
different--
connectivity, device.
And even with the
mature markets,
the device situation might
be very much different.
For example, I'm from Korea.
Korans love big screen.
We call them phablets.
And the economy
could be different
even if the market seems good.
The purchasing power
of users are different.
And sometimes even though all
these other technical scenes
seem OK, content policy
could be something
that could hold your
service from really
going into that market.
And app market size itself and
the maturity of the app market
is one of the things
that you should
consider before going global.
But I'm not going to
go into details on this
because we have a wonderful
session coming right
after this.
It's Building for Billions
happening on stage five.
So after this, you're
interested in more
in building for emerging
markets, go to stage five
and check that out.
So back to what makes
Asian different.
We just love
different characters,
and we love the characters
in a way a little bit
different from Western culture.
Of course there are loyal
fans of characters everywhere,
but in Asia, it's more like
it's embedded to our lives.
This is an example of Pokemon
game from the Pokemon company.
And as you can see, just
imagine from the structure,
the game itself is something
that you might easily
understand what the logic is.
But this game is a hit,
and the users love it
because they love the Pokemon.
And another difference
between Western and Eastern
is about the high
context culture.
This may have started from
Chinese characters conveying
a lot of meanings
in single words.
This is Mixi's Monster Strike.
And there are promotional images
from-- on the left side, Japan,
on the right side, global.
This is so apparent
difference, right?
For Japanese users, if you give
them the screen on the right,
they would feel like something
is missing or this is foreign.
If on the Western
eyes, if you see
the image on the left
sides, you will think,
oh they need a designer.
So keep that in mind.
And I want you to
pay close attention
to this part, the
live operation.
Have any of you heard
about the live operation?
Raise your hand if you have.
Oh good.
Yeah.
I will take simple
examples of life operations
to give you an idea.
It's basically a stage
of app that evolves
with the user interaction.
One of the early stage of live
operation will be live chatting
with the users through
game master, AKA GM's.
Game developers, you
would know what it is.
You have a accounts
within the game
and a chatting system
within the game,
and Game Masters reaches
out to users asking,
you know, I think you're
enjoying this game,
but you could even enjoy this
game even more if you do this.
Or they get their feedback.
Somebody would say,
well, this game
is getting kind of
boring after stage 43.
And then the Game Master
could understand and take that
and implement it
in a way that could
be more interesting to users.
It's a very good way of
engaging with the users.
Recently, the successes we
have seen in live operation is
the collaboration with the IP's.
This, again, is the example
from Mixi's Monster Strike.
They partner with Japan's long
loved character, Evangelion.
And they took the
world of Evangelion
and placed it in the game,
and users, they just love it.
And this is what keeps
the users engaging
and keeps new user inflow even
though game has been out there
for more than several months.
And live operations
are doing events
at the right moment
at the right time.
You see this is a revenue graph
from an actual developer based
in Korea and Japan.
And you see a lot of spikes.
That is not usual
for other markets,
and this is because we have
direct carrier billing, which
has a cap that refreshes on
the first day of the month.
So people, they have a budget
that they can spend more on.
And as you can see, the spike
gets even bigger and bigger
because developers who really do
the live operations right take
the moments and give the best
of events and promotions that
users cannot say no to.
And it's the time where they
have a willingness to pay,
full willingness to pay.
A good example would be
a Netmarble Future Fight.
I love this game.
I've been having so much time
finding the characters I love.
In this game, they had a
promotion on the Black Friday.
You might have done
similar stuffs already.
And they announced with
a really nice deal.
And they saw 869%
increase in revenue
compared to the previous
day, which means
they're creating the spikes.
And in a game, if
you want to keep
the lifetime of the
game longer and longer,
these spikes are really
necessary to keep the revenue
growing.
It means that users are engaging
back to your service or game.
So what I call told you
was about the differences
between somewhat Western
and Eastern cultures.
Now I will talk about even
more differences among the APAC
countries.
So this is the icon
screenshot of Japan and Korea.
Can you feel the difference?
Yeah.
So in our team, we would say,
if they don't have a nose,
it's Japanese icon.
If they have a nose
and it's a women
and they're very slim and
beautiful, it's usually Korean.
The users like different
types of images,
and they even like different
type of game plays.
For Korean, it's more about
PVP, meaning one-to-one battles.
And for Japan, it's not
that people don't enjoy PVP,
it's more like Japanese users
prefer collaborative play
a little more.
So to give you a
better idea, let
me show you-- and it's a good
clips-- of their TV commercials
showing this difference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is Korean Game,
Netmarble's KON.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[SPEAKING KOREAN]
JHYUN CHUNG: It's
based on one PVP play.
-[SPEAKING KOREAN]
-You are in KON.
[END PLAYBACK]
JHYUN CHUNG: So the video
is very much focused
on single person, right?
And let's take a look
at Mixi's TV commercial.
Now, you see a lot of
people to begin with.
And they have
incorporated this culture
of matsuri, which is
festival within the game
to show that this
is sort of a game
that you can take the feeling
of matsuri into your phone
and experience that
collaborative play.
So it is so different even
among the APAC market.
So what you have to do-- I'm
not trying to discourage you--
what I'm trying
to tell you is you
need to understand
there could be
even more differences in the
markets where you don't know.
And if you explore
a little more,
you'll be able to
see and pick up
this kind of little
subtle differences
that works well
in these markets.
Let's explore what
you can actually
do better in APAC markets.
I'll try to break down
into four sections.
First three is more
like a process.
You have to understand your
market, plan it, and go.
And second, we will talk about
how to better localize the app.
And third, I will
explain a little bit more
in depth about live
operation and how
you would want to do operations
in that local country.
And lastly, we will
tell you about what
you can use from Google's
tools to make this more
easier for you.
These are seasonings,
images of seasonings
sold in Southeast Asia market.
So if you want to casually
cook for yourself,
whatever, like
exotic dishes, you
could just follow the
recipe and put everything
that they tell you to do.
But if you want to be a cook and
if you want to sell your dish,
you really have to understand
the ingredients that
goes within.
So in this part, I'll tell you
about a little bit of facts
and some of the insights
of the APAC market.
And before we move onto
that, before knowing
what is out there, you have
to know your intentions.
What is your priority?
What's more important to you?
Is it revenue?
Or is it install?
This makes difference
in which countries
that you will want
to focus first.
For Japan and Korea, it's a
country with a lot of revenue
and great number of installs.
But the cost of
marketing it's very high.
Contrary to that,
Southeast Asia,
it has huge install potential,
and the cost of marketing
is low.
So if your priority is clearly
on the other side, check.
It's a easy decision
you can make.
But if you want to
go to everywhere,
try Taiwan and Hong Kong.
They have users with high ARPPU,
average spending per spending
users, and they're
very much loyal.
So if you want to test
out your service or game,
these markets could be a
good place to start with.
Now, when we talk about
Southeast Asia market,
we're talking about these
six key markets-- Singapore,
Thailand, Malaysia, Indonesia,
Philippines, and Vietnam.
And we talked about
installs, but they
do make a sizable revenue
in Indonesia, Philippines,
and Vietnam.
And since we have the
map, I did a little dot
drawing across of what
type of game category
works best in each region.
And it was interesting
because on the northern side
of these countries, we see
hardcore RPGs doing really
well.
On the below, we see
more of a diverse type
of game doing well.
This could be due
to several reasons,
and it could be due to
the device performance,
but this is how it is.
And the other thing
that I've tried doing
was to color based on what
messenger platform works
best for each region.
I thought I would see
some dominant color,
but it betrayed me.
And there's a lot of diverse
colors in this map, which
means if you want to use the
best out of each platforms,
you may have to think
about having strategies
for each market,
multiple builds.
But we have prepared
Play Games service
and Google sign in that you
can use in all these countries.
So if you want to
scale your business,
you can use our social logins.
And preparing your
app from the start.
Material design works well.
Prepare to have your
app strings separated so
that you can easily update.
And system elements
are really different
among these countries.
And if you haven't
taken them out,
users might feel the
service [INAUDIBLE].
Few examples-- material design.
Asian users are already
very much educated
in how the material design is,
how Android foreign factors
play in.
So you don't have to
teach the users how
to use the app if you use
basic structure of the material
design.
And I told you about
separating the app strings
because language
is all different.
Even for Taiwan and Hong Kong,
they use traditional Chinese.
But if you want to have voice
control or have audio content,
they speak a different Chinese.
Cantonese and Mandarin.
And Indonesia, Bahasa
works really well
if you want to pick
up the performance.
And on the system elements
side, if a dating app asked me--
I'm born and raised in
Korea-- and they ask me,
how tall are you
in feet and inches?
I can't answer
because I don't know.
I know that I'm 167
centimeters high,
but I don't know it in feet.
So if you give that
to Asian users what
you are most used to in US,
that doesn't work that way.
So please be prepared that
the units will be different.
Also same with the days.
Now, we touched a brief
about ingredients.
You can always learn
more on yourself.
So let's talk about the
cooking, localization.
So when you it comes
to localization,
we say that it is a
process for those who
are just starting to localize.
If you're already an expert,
just go dive into it.
But if you're starting
to do a localization,
this could be in a process.
So start simple.
Just try using auto translation
in your app description.
Because just by doing that,
is opening your front door
to the new users and
inviting them to come in.
And if you think
you see some actions
or responses from
that market, now you
can start getting more serious.
Let them know that
you are starting
to care for them in their
market by translating your app.
And in the third phase, you
have to really go in and operate
in local language
in a native voice.
In the Play store, you can
localize the trailer, icon,
title, description,
and key images.
And this may sound
easy, or this may sound
very difficult to some of you.
But there are developers
who do it in a perfection.
This is Polaris
Office from Korea
and their app promotional
screen in Japan.
My Japan colleague,
Evan, right over there.
He told me that it's
hard for Japanese
to even think about
that this app is not
for a Japanese developer
because they reached
to a point of perfection.
If you see in the image,
they show the examples
within the app in Japanese.
And that sort of detail
can lead users to feel
more attached to the service.
And on the Cookpad
side, they not only
localize the listings
in the language,
they localize with the
local food content.
So they would show the food
that the local users would most
love.
And if you want
to see the impact,
one password I've
worked with the team.
It's Canadian team.
I love the team.
And it only took them two weeks
to finish up their localization
because they had it ready
in their apps streams.
And right after that, they
saw 100% increase in install
in Korean market.
I think this is something
that is easy for you
to make decision on.
But not all services are
utility, or it's simple.
But just think that how
much potential it brings
once you just start localizing.
So went to choose between
single and multiple builds.
If your app is targeting more
to-- we saw the social services
with [INAUDIBLE], the
specific market service,
you should think about
building multiple builds.
But then it means
more resources,
engineering resources
needed for you,
but the service and the content
will be much more tailored
to local users.
If you want to
keep a scale of it,
single build is your answer.
And even within
the single build,
you can still localize
the business model.
The alarm clock app--
they have a lot of items.
They placed the strategy
differently among the regions.
So for example, in Japan,
they have 35 paid items.
In contrary to Southeast Asia
markets, they only have 15.
But the ads frequency is
very high in that market.
So balance up your monetization
strategy based on the country.
And sub dollar pricing works.
We have enabled
sub dollar pricing
in 18 countries in Google Play.
I told you about the
economy and the purchasing
power of each country.
And in some other countries,
$1 doesn't mean a single item.
It means like your days wage.
So in that countries,
lower your prices.
And then you not only
get more revenue,
you get more engaging users.
And if you're interested
on earning money on Play,
we have a session prepared
9 AM tomorrow morning.
It's early.
I know.
It's the last day.
But this is worth your time.
Please go and check out.
OK.
So you have
understood the market.
You have your app ready
in perfect localization.
Now, what's your next step?
What do you have to do?
Now you have to really
dive into that sea,
to that ocean with a high tide.
Operate your app
with the local voice.
So DomiNations by
Nexon-- they communicate
with users in Japanese
when they leave
response in their reviews.
And coming back to the Mixi's
case on live operation,
let me give you a little more
detail about what they did.
So on the first round of
collaboration with Evangelion,
they had three, four characters
into the balls, which
is the key of the
game, and they created
four stages that reflect
the world in the animation.
And they saw the record
breaking high number of user
who simultaneously
played the game, which
is important for
collaborative Play games.
And on the second round,
they did it after six months.
They even saw more higher
engagement with end users.
The record was broken again.
And this is how you
start engaging users
back to your service
even you've already
have a collaboration again.
And one other thing is I did
this with my Korean developers
together.
In Taiwan, there was
a trend sometime.
Some of you may
know this already.
So like woman would
stand at the back time
on the wall with her back.
And the guy will be
hitting the wall protecting
or like getting onto the woman.
And the hitting the wall was
like a buzzword in Taiwan.
And Korean developers
caught this,
and they create an in-app item
especially for Taiwan market.
And the result, users loved it.
They saw two times
more install just right
after launching these
new in-app items.
Sometimes acquisition
really helps.
Cookpad acquired a lot of
communities and startups
and recipes in the cook
service content business.
And it was one of the
most effective way
of expanding their
boundaries so quickly
and taking users
from that countries.
This is the case from
Netmarble's Future Fight.
When they went into Taiwan,
they did the marketing
that works in that region.
So they did Mobile
UA, TVC, Wrapping Bus,
which probably isn't
familiar to many of you.
And they did a lot of
consumer exhibition and events
to engage more with the users.
They invested.
This case is EvilBane
with Netmarble.
You can also collaborate
with local celebrities
or local influencers.
In that way, users feel that
through the local celebrated
image, that game or app service
is more relevant to you.
Alarm Mon did a really
creative CPG collaboration
with a juice bottle.
They had a QR code in the
juice leading to the website
where it showed about the app.
And after this,
they saw two times
the growth in that market.
By now, I hope you
have the chance
to think about what
you could start trying
and what you could
implement in your market.
Let me tell you about
the Google tools.
If you're at the first
stage of going global,
use the APK translation service
in our developer console.
It is not a perfect quality,
but it is good enough
for the local eyes.
And we recently announced that
if you have a local pricing,
we now round up the currency
to something that makes
more sense in the local market.
And you could price it
in a way that you want.
But the thing you
have to keep in mind
is always launch, test,
and iterate the process
to see what really
works for your region.
And you can do this
through analyzing
the users in conversion funnel
in the developer console.
Now you can see by the
countries which country had
the most install and the
conversion rate of that country
was how much.
And you can also analyze
the ratings by the country
and understand what is wrong
with certain countries.
Even we translate the feedbacks
for you in your language.
And a case that I want to share
is Creative [INAUDIBLE] Potu.
It's a very pretty pink
dolphin, kids app, lovely.
But one day they saw a huge drop
in user rating in Philippines.
That is after they launched.
And one of the user feedback was
that Boto meant something bad
in Philippines.
So they took the
response from that review
and changed the name Potu.
And after that, they're doing
great in the Philippines.
And do a lot of store
listing experiments.
You can A/B test your
icons, your app description,
your trailers.
Tell you a case
about Monster Strikes
international expansion.
They tested their icon.
This is the winner.
They also tested the
app descriptions--
like the key
description messages.
And they tested the
screen shot and the video.
In a way, they planned to
see the maximum efforts.
And after this, they saw
60% increase in conversion
before and after the test.
And in a world where
the marketing costs
cost per install is
going higher and higher,
improving the conversion
rate is really
critical for the business.
And then afterwards, they start
testing the in app experiences.
If you want to know
more about game side
and about how to be more
successful in Google Play,
you have a session
tomorrow 10 AM.
So try not miss it again.
I show you some
examples from Netmarble.
We have Netmarble's Duke, coming
in to speak for the event.
So you'll be able to hear
more about the examples
that he can give.
OK so kind of wrapping all
the things that I discussed,
I'll share two success
cases from developers.
And this will kind of
help you to organize
what we have discussed today.
Joycity's Game of Dice
was success in Hong Kong.
Do you remember
that I said you have
to plan ahead of your strategy?
Game of Dice planned the
localization strategy
before they launch.
So they had a team
who could best
localize in the local
language by including
traditional Chinese speaker
and simplified Chinese speaker
and having a check and balance
process within the localization
team.
And then they would check
the localization level
with the Korean team
in a processed way
so that they don't
miss out a single word.
And the [INAUDIBLE],
they collaborated
with celebrity that's very
popular in Hong Kong market.
And they collaborated
with YouTube creators
to let the game know in a
more familiar way to users.
But the importance of
A/B testing is here.
They thought celebrity icons
would work better than the game
character image icons.
But when they
tested it, actually
the game character image
worked better in performance.
So you have to test an area to
see what works best for you.
They did marketing that makes
sense in the local markets.
They create Webtoons.
In the subway, they
created engaging videos
that explain of the game play.
And they wrapped buses.
And I will show you the
Musixmatch's win in Japan.
So truth or myth?
Honestly, the DD's,
like us, we thought
Japan market is
almost impossible
to crack in terms of service or
content from developers abroad.
But Musixmatch did it.
They localize.
They even localized the app
experience for Japanese users.
And what they saw
is 300% increase,
and they was ranked number one
in music category in Japan.
What they did was they
personalized to Japanese users,
localized deeply
of all the things
that they can localize
in play, and they
did a lot of A/B testing, did
analytics from the developer
console, and really worked
with the local market
experts on FGIs and
learning more and more
of the local market.
I told you in the
opening session
how Google Play is
the magical door,
and the door is open
for all of the you.
It's open for everyone
who wants to go
and dive into new markets.
We will keep listening to
the feedbacks that you have
and difficulties that you had
going into the global market.
And we will make the product
better and better for you.
You already have
a better product
that announce this time
with more countries
that you can test your A/B
testing on simultaneously
and of the price charming, price
roundings, that we provide.
So keep trying, and let us know
what works and what doesn't.
And we'll try our best to be
better platform for you too.
If you have any questions,
you can update on the Spaces.
And since I have
five minutes left,
I may be able to take one or
two questions from the audience.
The mic is in the center.
If you have a question,
you can do this.
And I will have my friend
BD's from other regions.
Raise your hand if
you're a BE for Korea.
There's people who are part
responsible for these APAC
markets.
So if you want to connect
with us more, find us.
We'll be here.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]